[Applaudissements]
george michael bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes plutôt rare à la
télévision je crois que c'est la
première fois que vous participez à un
talk show en france nous
sommes
probablement oui en effet c'est
à moi que je ne me trompe ou que je ne
rappelle pas non je crois qu'on est fait
c'est la toute première fois en tout cas
que je participe à demi mesure comme
celle ci merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle
[Applaudissements]
george michael
george michael 80 millions d'albums
vendus alors georges l'album s'appelle
patience parce que finalement on a
attendu huit ans un nouveau cd de
chansons originales en 1999 il y avait
eu songs from de la century qui étaient
des reprises et en 2002 vous avez sorti
deux singles 1 qui s'appelle fric est un
qui s'appelle shoot de drogue et avant
de parler de vos nouvelles compositions
voudrait qu'on dise un mot de ces deux
chansons fliquer shoot de drogue parce
qu'elle figure sur votre nouvel album
qui s'appelle patience je le répète
alors ces deux chansons de colère deux
singles assez engagé dans fric vous
remettez en cause l'overdose du sexe à
la télévision vous dit qu'aujourd'hui
les jeunes sont pris en otage par la
pornographie
alors je sais pas s'ils sont vraiment
prise en otage en fait mais ce qui me
semble
qu'aucun effort n'est fait pour protéger
les jeunes lorsqu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent à gagner or malheureusement
disons que les considérations sociales
je sais pas comment les choses se
passent en france par exemple en
angleterre la plupart des enfants des
classes moyennes est une bourgeoise et
pas nécessairement d'ailleurs des
classes moyennes ou une télé dans leur
chambre à coucher dès l'âge de 8 ans
moi j'ai été choqué de voir lorsque je
regardais à la télévision
britannique
tout l'espace que je voyais
c'était des choses assez assez choquant
et je me suis dit que
j'avais des gamins qui avaient peur de
voir ce qu'ils faisaient ce qu'ils
voyaient surtout s'ils étaient très
jeunes alors j'essaie de faire un disque
qui qui parlerait de ce genre de
problèmes se fait qu'ils aient espèce de
bulldozer du sexe et de commerce du sens
constamment à la télévision et là et et
l'aspect agressif que ça peut avoir pour
un enfant de 10 ou 11 ans alors plutôt
plutôt que de me donner l'image de
quelqu'un qui approuvent la censure je
préférais simplement d'être à côté de
tout cela prendre position prend du
recul et me mettre dans ce contexte vous
dites comme angleterre vous avez vu en
deuxième partie de soirée à 22h30 des
émissions ont parlé facilement de
fétichisme et dont 10 nismo si
oui ça justement je trouve que c'est
pourquoi pas en fait mais
disons que pour moi c'était tout à fait
fascinant mais
disons que les anglais les britanniques
en général ils ont besoin de se
décoincer un peu ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'ils ont besoin de se
décoincer autour du sexe que maintenant
peut-être que la laine le contre coup
réactions à tout est finalement assez
simple finalement de se décoincer
pourquoi mais par contre je crois qu'il
ya une certaine paresse c'est la preuve
qu'il s'agisse de producteurs de télé ou
encore
des parents des enfants bizot qui j'en
fais pas très attention à ce que les
enfants voient la regarde à la télé et
puis y'a des choses quand même passé
assez hard le sexe sans âme ça vous
choque georges
moi ça allait beaucoup d'arrivées par
exemple
soit
sakic qui chaussent le sexe après tout
le sexe avec de l'amour c'est quand même
quelque chose de très différent et
beaucoup plus enrichissant
disons que le sexe sans âme enfin y'a
pas de problème avec ça alors l'autre
single qui est sorti en 2002 et que l'on
retrouve sur votre nouvel album donc
patience ses shoots de drogue alors
c'est une chanson qui est anti bush
antibes l'air il ya une vidéo qui a été
fait ou on voit tony blair qui danse
dans les pattes de bouche comme un chien
à quatre pattes et une autre séquence
vous êtes au lit avec la femme de tony
blair chérie blair alors vous avez été
très attaquées par les journaux
conservateurs suite à cette chanson et
suite à cette vidéo et vous répondez
finalement qu'à l'époque de la guerre en
2003 il ya un an
90% des anglais penser comme vous c'est
à dire 90 % des anglais était contre la
guerre en irak
enfin le chiffre se rapprochait
peut-être plutôt de 70% que 70 % était
contre la guerre a aucun frein et 90 %
des anglais disait non sauf si les lieux
des états unis les nations unies s'en
mêle alors évidemment ça fait un peu
sans taj assez spectaculaire de la
population qui est que l'on ne peut pas
ignorer lorsqu'on dans ce pays en guerre
quand même alors au début du mois vous
avez déclaré dans un journal qui
s'appelle big show parce que ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que george michael
s'exprime souvent dans les colonnes de
big is you qui est un journal de sdf en
angleterre ce une façon de les aider
parce que quand il s'exprime tout le
monde l'achète évidemment
dans big shoe vous dites c'est
effroyable pour ceux qui ont perdu des
enfants dans cette guerre de s'entendre
dire par tony blair que le monde est
plus sûr 1
disons que c'était quelque chose d'un
petit peu
inhumain de répéter ça à tout bout de
champ le raisonnement politique on le
comprend mais ils ont tous une heure les
dater un peu insensible à la douleur ce
qu'elle ait perdu des êtres chers ce qui
c'est empêcher la guerre
demandons au public de faire entendre sa
voix
je ne sais pas si on s'est rendu compte
que personne ne tiendrait compte de
leurs revendications et en fait la
question qu'il fallait se poser avant la
guerre
toutes les questions les réserves que
les gens avaient émises et bien ses
questions ses doutes étaient finalement
démontré
les gens avaient raison d'avoir des
doutes et moi ce qui m'a encouragé ses
devoirs
la sanction électorale on est
absolument horrible de se dire que un
groupe intégriste à une affluence en
quelque sorte sur l'élection au moins
vous avez une société
disait assez on en a marre d'être d'être
ignoré soit c'est une bonne chose c'est
ce que j'espère c'est que la passion du
peuple espagnol
pourra peut-être empêcher que ce genre
de seule chose se produise dans mon
propre pays
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà
voilà pour les deux chansons les deux
chansons qu'on connaissait du nouvel
album patience maintenant on va voir les
nouvelles alors vous avez dit george
michael j'ai longtemps cru que c'était
une fatalité que tous les compositeurs
donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes très tôt
et se dessécher ensuite et vous avez
découvert que c'était faux et quand on
écoute votre album on s'aperçoit que
votre talent de songwriter n'a pas
diminué
enfin qu'il va merci beaucoup c'est vrai
pink a
disons que la crainte la plus importante
peut savoir quand on est artiste c'est
justement de perdre sa créativité
exemple
ce genre de situation notamment dans
l'histoire de la musique pop et même
parmi les meilleurs paroliers les
meilleurs
quelque chose qui m'a toujours
effrayée je crois que la seule façon de
protéger justement contre cela ce qu'a
justement de risque de se et de se
dessécher et bien c'est de protéger ma
propre santé mentale et de m'éloigner
autant que possible de toute la vie
publique et et du showbiz ont rassemblé
que
2 est devenu beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup modeste que l'on pourrait
imaginer
qu'ils ont perdu justement leur talent
d'écriture justement ils mènent des vies
très glamour avec des gens très entouré
toutes sortes d'activités flamboyant des
super vilains
les meilleures soirées et compagnie ça
m'intéresse pas
et probablement c'est peut-être la
raison pour laquelle je suis encore ici
aujourd'hui voilà donc vous avez une vie
aussi plus apaisé il faut le dire parce
qu'après les deux chansons dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure fruit qui chute de
dog on trouve au contraire une écriture
très très calme avec beaucoup de recul
et vous dites 2003 et ma première bonne
année depuis dix ans c'est vrai
c'est plus que dix ans mais puissant
disons que 2003 a été pour moi la
première année depuis longtemps tout cas
où je me suis senti vraiment productif
et je veux je veux que les choses
restent ainsi alors parmi les nouvelles
chansons il ya une chanson qui s'appelle
john elvis are dead john et elvis sont
morts évidemment un hommage à presley et
à lennon
il me semble enfin je pense que cette
chanson sera
la pièce maîtresse de la génération
de stents il me semble qu'avec le temps
cette cette chanson
gagnera des parties importantes de
l'histoire alors il ya une autre chanson
sur l'album patients ce qui s'appelle
mada a deux bras d'amma mère avait un
frère ou vous raconter de george michael
que le frère de votre mère votre oncle
dont était homosexuel elle vous l'a dit
à l'âge de 17 ans et elle vous raconte
aussi ce jour-là que ce cet homme votre
oncle s'était suicidé le jour de votre
naissance et votre mère vous disait
souvent que vous lui faisiez pensé à lui
c'est à dire à la fois
sensible créatif gay aussi et lui c'est
tuer parce qu' il pouvait pas imaginer
arriver à réaliser dans la vie ce qu'il
voulait réaliser et et finalement vous
vivez un peu
laventure de cet oncle à sa place d'une
certaine façon dont
je ne vais quand même pas dire que
oui je sais ce que ressentent et mon
oncle cela étant je crois que l'on peut
supposer sans risque de se tromper que
que ça c'est que c'est en tout cas dans
les années cinquante a sûrement été une
source de dépression vaut lui et c'est
la raison sans doute pour laquelle il
s'est suicidé alors à travers cette
chanson ce que j'ai voulu faire c'est
justement de te montrer comment les des
évolutions qui se sont produites au
moins dans sept autres régions du monde
cette évolution a été dans le bon sens
ça va évidemment je rencontre beaucoup
d'homophobie notamment dans la presse
par exemple relève mais malgré tout cela
même si on dit toutes sortes de choses
quand même je suis libre et personne ne
pas m'enfermer parce que j'aime les
personnes que j'aime ou je fais l'amour
avec les
avec lequel je fais l'amour et c'est
donc une célébration de cette liberté
façon de rappeler à tous et surtout à la
communauté gaie que cette liberté est
récente pourquoi avoir attendu pour
faire votre âge ou thing d'être surpris
dans ses toilettes à los angeles
pourquoi l'avoir pas fait avant alors
que des amis à vous par exemple bode
george vous disais effet le fais le
pourquoi avoir attendu d'être pris
être ouvertement homosexuel c'est je
crois fondamental pour n'importe quel
mot sexuelle et dès qu'on peut le dire à
ses amis et à sa famille p il vaut mieux
le dire tout de suite le plus tôt est le
mieux mais lorsqu'on tenait une
célébrité homosexualiste dans la presse
dans les médias c'est pas nécessairement
ce que le public attend
j'aurais tort de dire que je ne suis pas
traités différemment par la presse
parce que depuis depuis que j'ai annoncé
mon homosexualité il les choses ont
changé le public
évidemment on a remarqué
je crois qu'une grande partie du public
le savait avant le cominois je les dis
insinué de bien des façons d'ailleurs je
n'ai jamais nié l'existence de mon
premier partenaire
de l'édition d'hier enfin c'était
surtout en fait mais crainte de la
réaction de la presse je comprendrais
tout à fait aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui ne
veut pas être réduit à un stéréotype
homosexuels gain final parce qu'on est
bien plus que ça mais c'est bien triste
qu'un homme ou une femme d'ailleurs
homosexuels doivent consacrer toute son
énergie à cacher son identité sexuelle
mais tant que l'on ne pourra pas être ce
que l'on veut lorsque le fait d'être
homosexuel est considéré comme
réduction de la personnalité je pense
que les choses peut-être son meilleur en
france qu'ailleurs à la méthode qu'on
sera réduit à un simple stéréotypes
alors ne faut pas forcer les gens à
faire leur coming out est inquiet alors
depuis cet outing george michael vous
êtes passé je dirais de l'autre côté du
miroir vous avez l'air d'être mieux
beaucoup plus apaisé vous assumez
vraiment bien à votre différence et je
dis pas simplement votre différence
sexuelle parce que ça vous le faisait
avant mais aussi celles que vous
ressentiez depuis votre enfance à
l'école d'abord votre nom c'est vrai que
vous appelez giorgio de kyriakos
panayiotou alors évidemment c'est
compliqué quand on était à l'école
d'ailleurs le père se fait appeler jack
panos ensuite votre taille vous mesurez
1 m 82 vous êtes avoue être un peu trop
grand quand vous êtes petit c'est le cas
de le dire et puis votre corps vous
étiez un peu empoté et alors là
finalement 2-2 puis vous avez l'air
d'assumer ça complètement normalement
non
washington may hamm seulement disent oh
que je suis quelqu'un
qui était connu très tôt et 3 et j'ai
moi même j'ai pu voir traitant que la
plupart des ambitions s'appuie sur des
sur des dysfonctionnements
c'est curieux mais c'est les défauts qui
vous pousse à
j'ai voulu m'appuyer sur l'expérience
pour justement peut-être france et des
plaies d'enfance nous portons tous ses
blessures une autre enfant c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire c'est de m'occuper
surtout de l'esprit de ma tranquillité
d'esprit pour régler des problèmes et
avec un peu de courage je crois qu'on
peut régler tous les problèmes rapporte
dans sa tête à l'âge de 40 ans
aujourd'hui je pense que j'ai réglé la
plupart des problèmes qui se sont posés
je me sens vraiment effectivement à
l'aise alors aujourd'hui donc on a parlé
d'une nouvelle vie mais demain encore
plus puisque le l'album patience qui
sort en ce moment est le dernier album
que vous distribuerez par la voie
normale vous dites à partir du prochain
je diffuserai mes chansons sur internet
gratuitement peut-être que les femmes
feront des dons à des associations
caritatives
mais voilà ça sera plus en vente dans
les bacs est ce que c'est un nouveau
pied de nez que vous faites aux maisons
de disques parce qu'on sait que vous
avez des problèmes avec avec sony vous
les avez traité d'esclavagistes
aujourd'hui des routes sortait l'album
chez eux est ce que c'est une façon de
leur faire un pied de nez
ils vont s'enrichir d'ici là ils vont
considérablement son chien et la savoie
disons que c'est simplement pour moi
comme je je veux vraiment pouvoir
maîtriser chaque partie de ma vie je
veux justement maîtriser la suivante
j'ai pas que j'ai traversé une période
de grandes difficultés oui je voudrais
justement éviter de retomber dans les
écueils d'hier
dd grosse pression je suis conforté dans
ma
non sélection
chanson
tous les trois ou quatre on me juge
là-dessus terre c'est vrai pour tous les
artistes musicaux
mon angoisse par rapport à tout cela
c'est ce qui m'a joué 10
août et la joie d'écrire de composer et
quand même mais disons qu'ils avaient
une certaine angoisse qui qui qui gênait
tout cela et puis way depuis un an je me
suis dit j'ai eu le rappelle pourquoi
pourquoi je fais de la musique et je me
suis vraiment rappeler les causes
profondes et j'ai voulu dépasser ses
angoisses et me dire que la musique être
une source de plaisir et non pas
d'angoissé et là avec ça
c'est pas à travers les médias que je
vais y arriver c'est à dire que l'avenir
de la célébrité est toujours un peu
douteux je sais pas si c'est vraiment
une vie s'ils s'y aguerrir que cela
mélange pas que c'est beaucoup plus
agréable de donner à ceux qui aiment la
musique et qui ne la trouveront plaire
dubuc leur donner la possibilité la
télécharger gratuitement sur internet et
puis ça me donne l'idée que peut-être de
leur côté il vaudrait peut-être
participer à une cause caritative prévue
en sont pas obligés mais ils sont très
méchants ils peuvent juste et les
téléchargent de la musique gratuite et
c'est tout mais avec un grain de
générosité avec un wedge antilles est je
crois qu'il y aura des gens qui seront
contents d'être versé un peu d'argent
des déchets à ses passions caritatives
alors
george michael vous rêvez d'une nouvelle
vie plus tranquille un petit peu loin
des problèmes de médias d'argent etc
mais vous savez l'argent ça existe quand
même alors on va vous faire une
interview pour ton bien
alors que george michael pour combien
d'argent
enregistre auriez vous un album sous
votre vrai nom georges aux kyriakos pas
mal du tout
voilà
[Musique]
peut-être
ça poserait pas de problème mais il vrai
que tout le monde apprenne à prononcer
le nom correctement
giorgos panahi tout par ailleurs
panayiotou cale à cale
pour combien d'argent chante auriez-vous
en live là maintenant
[Applaudissements]
bien
faire venir un fourgon blindé
camions pleins de sous pour combien
d'argent accepteriez-vous de dîner avec
bush et blair
gratuitement c'est je le fais
pas qu'il inviterait
franchement mais pour combien d'argent
vous referiez le groupe wham
voilà out dida à gaza ou encore
jeffrey son problème je ne pense pas que
je serai très chaud pour le faire tant
que peu importe combien je demanderai
fait ce que lui seraient pas d'accord
pour combien d'argent vous venez chanter
pour l'anniversaire de ma fille
on en parle à tout à l'heure pour
combien d'argent vous mettez torse nu là
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
combien d'argent vous rester jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission un job
que je trouve mon avion la chine avec
ses vrais chèques c'est vrai merci
d'être venus en tous les cas il faut
être sûr de ne rien rater le in auditive
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou